[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui la nouvelle
génération de téléphonie mobile 5 g
véritable enjeu commercial mais aussi
géopolitique ces technologies
cristallise les tensions de plus en plus
vive entre les états unis et la chine
où en est-on actuellement dans le
déploiement de la 5g à travers le monde
le 8 octobre à washington annonce un
financement de 600 millions de dollars
pour tester la 5g dans cinq bases
militaires une décision qui se conjugue
bien avec la stratégie américaine visant
à accélérer le déploiement du réseau de
nouvelle génération à travers tout le
pays
pourtant le leader actuel de la course à
la 5 gr est la chine qui ouvre des
milliers de stations de base par semaine
et vend son équipement 5g à l'étranger
cette activité sème l'inquiétude à
washington qui adopte une série de
sanctions contre le géant des télécoms
chinois ou avait et appelle ses alliés à
faire de même le royaume uni est la
suède suivent le pas ainsi qu'un certain
nombre de pays asiatiques et certains
pays européens
pourtant la majorité des pays africains
où l'influencé chinoise reste assez
forte rejette le blocage de ou à veille
en europe hormis quelques réticences ou
avait et sa 5 g ce sont à l'aise en
espagne en autriche en hongrie et en
suisse la france quand elle adopte une
position médiane sans interdire
complètement fou avec paris limite
fortement l'utilisation de son
équipement
[Musique]
mais avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il
faut savoir sur cette nouvelle
génération de réseaux mobiles 5 g c'est
le blitz comme son nom l'indiqué la 5g
est la cinquième génération de réseaux
mobiles qui va donc succéder à la 4g
parmi les promesses phares de la 5g on
retrouve d'abord un débit mobile qui
dépassera de loin le réseau local à haut
débit le plus rapide actuellement avec
une vitesse pouvant atteindre 10 gigas
par seconde
la 5g sera jusqu'à 100 fois plus rapides
que la 4g pourtant la caractéristique
principale de la 5g c'est le temps de
latence
c'est le délai de transit d'une donnée
entre le moment où elle est envoyée
jusqu'au moment où elle est reçue celui
ci sera divisée par dix par rapport à la
4g avec un temps de réponse d'apple une
milliseconde
c'est très activité permettra donc de
révolutionner les domaines du transport
de la médecine de la robotique de
l'énergie et du bâtiment
l'autre avantage incontournable de la 5g
est la densité accrue avec elle
dix fois plus d'objets pourront être
connectés au même réseau
simultanément plus précisément la 5g
pourra supporter au moins un million
d'appareils par kilomètre carré
une caractéristique indispensable tenant
compte du fait que le nombre d'objets
connectés pourrait avoisiner les 50
milliards d'ici 2025 la course à la 5g
est bel et bien lancée
les deux puissances mondiales que sont
les états unis et la chine se met à
déployer à toute vitesse leurs réseaux
de nouvelle génération
le leader actuel de cette compétition et
la chine elle a le plus grand nombre de
stations de base déployée et d'abonnés
au service 5 g sur l'entreprise de
téléphonie ou avec dépasse de loin ses
concurrents dans le volume des
livraisons d'équipements 5g à l'étranger
évidemment cette activité inquiète de
plus en plus les états unis qui aspirent
eux aussi à ce leadership
et pour y arriver d'un côté les
autorités américaines accélère le
déploiement des stations de base et de
l'autre mettre des bâtons dans les roues
de leurs concurrents chinois
en effet washington
ou à veille de vouloir espionner ses
utilisateurs et sous prétexte de
défendre les intérêts des utilisateurs
américains les états unis adoptent les
unes après les autres des sanctions
restreignant l'activité du géant chinois
en appelant leurs alliés à faire de même
certains comme l'australie ou la suède
suivent le pas d'autres choisissent le
camp adverse par exemple un bon nombre
de pays africains préfèrent ou avait à
ses concurrents en raison des conditions
avantageuses qu'il propose en amérique
latine en asie ou en europe les
positions d'où avait reste tout aussi
forte
la france quand elle adopte une position
médiane sans bannir directement
l'équipement ou avait et limite pourtant
son utilisation par ces opérateurs
mobiles quel est donc l'enjeu
stratégique de cette course acharnée à
la 5g
quelle est la stratégie de pékin pour
conserver sa domination sur le marché de
la 5g enfin comment les sanctions
américaines
ont-elles affecter l'activité du géant
des télécoms chinois pour répondre à ces
questions nous rejoignons et yann maël
l'arrière docteur en droit social et
spécialistes du numérique
monsieur l'arrière bonjour bonjour
pourquoi pensez-vous qu'aujourd'hui les
états unis sont largement dépassés par
la chine dans le domaine de la 5g alors
y'a pas du coup on est sur des
technologies qu'ils soient un petit peu
mondialisée ont déçu on est vraiment au
coeur de la mondialisation des échanges
les etats unis sont très bons ils ont
créé des choix technologiques notamment
dans l'intelligence artificielle et ses
draps mais ils ont pas ils ont un petit
peu négligé 7,5 g et voilà du coup ils
ont ils ont pas investi cette
technologie il souhaite maintenant créer
des consortiums américain il y avait
donald trump qui avait proposé de mettre
des milliards sur la table pour que des
acteurs américains se saisisse de la
question
mais aujourd'hui voilà les les
opérateurs
de téléphonie américaine se repose
essentiellement en soit sur les
technologies européennes soit sur les
technologies asiatiques c'est un choix
stratégique qui a été fait il ya là
plusieurs années et qu'ils révèlent
aujourd'hui on va dire désastreux en
tout cas pour donald trump washington
insiste sur le fait que l'équipement je
suis noir représente un véritable danger
pour sa sécurité nationale
est ce vrai selon vous y at il des
failles dans la 5g chinoise alors les
arguments américains se tiennent mais
qu'ils ne sont pas forcément très
objectif puisque les etats unis ont
aussi des ports intérêts commerciaux et
on a vu ces derniers mois une vraie
bataille entre les états unis et la
chine sur le front commercial puisque la
balance commerciale américaine est
déséquilibré pour revenir à la question
il est certain que il ya des soupçons
toujours quand on parle de deux
technologies qui sont très très proches
de la souveraineté des états qu'il
puisse y avoir à l'intérieur des
technologies des portes d'entrée ou des
portes de sortie pour les informations
qui ne seraient pas connues des
acheteurs mais qui serait connue de ceux
qui vendent les technologies c'est
exactement la même question qui se pose
sur les smartphones et là on boit sur
une technologie particulière mais qui a
vocation finalement à être un petit peu
le pilier de toutes les infrastructures
de communication
donc ça dépasse un smartphone là c'est
toutes les infrastructures et donc du
coup la question est très sensible
pourquoi selon vous les pays et les
opérateurs choisis style les sociétés de
télécoms chinoises en quoi sont-elles
meilleures alors je ne sais pas si elles
sont meilleures sur tout mais sur les
cinq gestes pour revenir au sujet c'est
certain que oui a investi massivement et
en amont par rapport à notamment nokia
qui est un peu le numéro deux en terme
this man et ils ont par exemple trois
fois plus de brevets sur la 5g et leurs
5 g coûte globalement moins chères que
celles des concurrents et elle est un
petit peu plus efficace donc oui ils ont
pris une longueur d'avancé un petit peu
le leader du marché de la 5g après ça ne
veut pas dire que les autres ceux qui
ont un petit peu de retard ou qui
auraient eu du retard comme ericsson ne
vont pas le rattraper et faire des
produits aussi performant surtout que là
aujourd'hui sont en train de rattraper
finalement les parts de marché qui leur
manquait et du coup ils sont capables
aussi d'être compétitif sur le prix
monsieur l'arrêt remercie beaucoup nous
allons poursuivre notre analyse tout de
suite mais nous vous retrouverons en fin
d'émission pour plus de détails sur la
question évidemment merci beaucoup
le 8 octobre 2001 le département
américain de la défense annonce un
financement de 600 millions de dollars
pour des tests de la 5g cette
expérimentation à grande échelle va se
dérouler sur cinq bases militaires avec
la participation de plusieurs géants de
télécoms comme à tianjin nokia ericsson
formation en réalité virtuelle
planification de mission utilisation des
robots et des drogues
ce n'est qu'une partie des exercices qui
seront réalisés à l'aide du réseau de
nouvelle génération 5 g ces tests
s'inscrivent bien dans la stratégie
américaine visant à accélérer le
déploiement de la 5g
c'est le plan 5g fast adopté il y a deux
ans par la commission fédérale des
communications le document fixe trois
objectifs clefs
tout d'abord c'est la libération des
fréquences radioélectriques et leurs
ventes aux opérateurs mobiles ensuite
vient le déploiement des stations de
base aujourd'hui il y en a à peu près 80
milles aux états unis enfin le dernier
point et l'adoption de la législation
qui permettrait d'accélérer le
déploiement de l'infrastructure
rien qu'en en juin 2020
26 propositions des lois sont soumises
au congrès par les députés républicains
pour fluidifier la mise en place de la
5g pourtant malgré tous ses efforts
washington est aujourd'hui largement
dépassé par pékin leader actuel de la
course quelques quinze mille stations de
base 5 g sont installées chaque semaine
en chine
le pays a en comptera plus de 600 milles
d'ici fin 2020 le nombre d'abonnés vient
de franchir récemment la barre de 100
millions contre 1 million d'abonnés aux
états unis et la chine ne cache pas son
ambition elle veut faire partie des
premiers pays à couvrir l'ensemble de
son territoire par ce réseau pourquoi
grâce à son ultra rapidité la 5g
permettra de moderniser l'ensemble des
moyens de production et donc par
conséquent d'augmenter ses bénéfices
dans les transports une révolution se
prépare voiture autonome et toutes
sortes de véhicules intelligents
pourront voir le jour grâce au temps de
latence de la 5g réduit au minimum deux
nouveaux horizons s'ouvrent pour la
médecine aussi téléconsultation
chirurgie à distance suivi des patients
tout cela de façon plus rapide et plus
fiable toutes ces transformations vont
booster l'économie mondiale et surtout
celle des pionniers de la scène j'ai
selon les prévisions de forbes la 5g
devrait créer 4,6 millions d'emplois
supplémentaires à travers le monde et
générer des bénéfices allant jusqu à
12,3 trillions de dollars en quinze ans
seulement
côté stratégique et les avantages sont
tout aussi nombreux coordination des
opérations tactiques en temps réel usage
de la réalité augmentée pour
l'entraînement des corps d'armée
automatisation des systèmes d'armes et
défense antimissile la 5g donnerait
également un nouvel élan au
développement des armes hypersonique
pour les guider sur des trajectoires
variable en échappant aux missiles
intercepteurs et il faut recueillir
élaboré et transmettre d'énormes
quantités de données en une fraction de
seconde des avantages dont washington
entend aussi profiter pleinement et qui
de ce fait accuse ou à wail
principal fournisseur d'équipements 5g
dans le monde d'espionnage pour la
première fois le géant chinois est mise
en cause début 2018
les services de renseignements
américains le soupçonnent d'espionner
ses utilisateurs selon washington le
géant des télécoms chinois utiliserait
le numéro i mais l'historique des sms et
des appels la position de l'appareil
mobile ou encore la liste des contacts
et les applications utilisées pour
récupérer les informations personnelles
de ses utilisateurs
toutes ces données pourraient donc être
transmise au gouvernement chinois ou
même à d'autres pays alliés de pékin
selon le wall street journal ou avait
aurait aidé au moins deux fois
certains dirigeants africains loyaux
envers pékin à espionner leurs opposants
politiques
les autorités chinoises accusent
washington de fausses accusations censé
détruire la réputation de la 5g chinoise
et afin de renforcer ses propres
positions sur le marché washington
impose toute une série de sanctions
contre le géant des télécoms chinois ou
avait il s'agit avant tout d'un décret
présidentiel datant de mai 2019 qui
interdit aux entreprises américaines de
s'équiper auprès de fournisseurs
étrangers jugés à risque une décision
qu'a les breaks qui vise surtout ou
avait en mai 2001 les états unis vont
encore plus loin en interdisant de
fournir les composants électroniques
semi conducteurs à la firme chinoise
une mesure qui s'étend aussi aux
entreprises non américaines qui vendent
ou avaient des puces élaboré à partir
d'une technologie américaine en août
2020 ou avait perd sa licence android
qui lui permettait de recevoir des mises
à jour de sécurité de google
cependant en plus de l'adoption de ces
sanctions les états unis incite
également leurs alliés à les rejoindre
toujours selon le wall street journal
les états unis lancent en 2018
une intense campagne de lobbying auprès
de ses partenaires afin de les persuader
de ne pas acheter l'équipement chinois
et certains cèdent à la pression
fin 2010 8 l'australie la
nouvelle-zélande le japon et même taïwan
restreint l'accès des équipements de
télécoms chinois à leur marché à partir
de 2020 l'étau se resserre encore plus
autour de haut avait en europe en
juillet le royaume uni et rejoint la
coalition anti ou avec l'achat de
nouveaux équipements fabriqués par le
groupe chinois sera interdite dès la fin
2020 tous les autres devront être
retirés du marché d'ici 2027
en octobre la suède banny aussi les
nouveaux équipements de ou à veille de
son réseau télécom 5 g pourtant tous les
alliés américains ne veulent pas infligé
à ou avait une telle sanction qui
sont-ils comment se poursuit la bataille
pour la conquête du marché d'équipement
5g enfin comment le réseau mobile at il
évolué pendant ces dernières décennies
la réponse après la pause la course à la
5g s'accélère dans les quatre coins du
monde
l'enjeu est hautement stratégique le
réseau de nouvelle génération octroiera
un avantage concurrentiel à la nation
qui réussira à le déployer avant les
autres et cela principalement grâce à
ses caractéristiques de loin plus
performante que celle des générations
précédentes
l histoire des réseaux mobiles
commencent en 1979 avec l'apparition au
japon du réseau 1 g l exemple et vite
suivie par un nombre de pays européens
et les états unis qui est riche en peu
de temps des stations de base sur leur
territoire et même si les paramètres
techniques de ces réseaux diffèrent d'un
pays à l'autre
1 j fonctionne partout via un réseau
cellulaire analogique
système qui ne manquent pas
d'inconvénient mauvaise qualité du son
transmission non sécurisés coûts énormes
du temps de conversation
une tentative d'améliorer la situation
est entreprise en 1982 la conférence
européenne d administration des postes
et télécommunications élabore la
première normes unifiées censé devenir
la base d'un futur réseau 2g gsm
son principe est simple la transmission
des données se fait en numérique ce qui
ouvre la possibilité d'utiliser les sms
pour la première fois la 2g apparaît en
finlande en 1991 et se propage en europe
d'abord et ensuite à travers le monde
pourtant les états unis choisissent de
suivre leur propre chemin
au lieu du gsm ils développent leurs
propres standards de gcd m à avec
l'émergence d'internet se pose la
question de l'augmentation de la vitesse
du réseau mobile c'est ainsi qu'apparaît
en 2000 la 3g
parmi ces promesses phares figurent une
vitesse pouvant aller jusqu'à 2048 kilo
bits secondes pour un client restant
immobile 3 184 kg beat secondes pour
celui qui se déplace à la vitesse d'un
piéton 128 kg beat seconde en voiture le
nouveau résout permettent en outre un
transfert simultané de voix et des
données numériques
tout cela apporte un bon nombre
davantage aux utilisateurs ils peuvent
désormais télécharger et à envoyer du
contenu multimédia passer des appels
vidéos regarder la télévision sur leur
smartphone accéder à un site web
pourtant l'évolution du réseau mobile
s'accélère avec l'apparition des
premiers smartphones la croissance en
popularité des réseaux sociaux et des
applications en ligne en mars 2008
l'union internationale des
télécommunications définit une série
d'exigences pour un réseau 4g
l'une d'entre elles concerne la vitesse
qui doit désormais atteindre ou même
dépasser les 100 mégabits par seconde
dans le monde la 4g commencent à être
déployés à partir de la fin 2009
entraînant une révolution numérique car
elles permettent aux utilisateurs de
regarder une vidéo en hd sans devoir
attendre qu'elles se chargent de
partager des photos et des vidéos en un
temps record de diffuser leur live
stream sur des réseaux sociaux en 2012
une amélioration de la 4g voit le jour
là 4j plus elle propose une vitesse de
connexion jusqu'à trois fois plus rapide
soit 300 méga bits par seconde de débit
théorique un nouveau pas dans
l'évolution du réseau mobile effet en
juin 2015
l'union internationale des
télécommunications publie un plan de
développement du réseau mobile 5 g la
course à la nouvelle technologie est
donc lancé s'ensuivent des essais actif
de la technologie 5g à travers le monde
vers 2019 la troïka des leaders et
définit d'abord c'est la chine qui
déploie près de 300 mille stations de
base sur son territoire ensuite vient la
corée du sud avec plus de 60000 antenne
diffusant le signal 5g le dernier dans
ce top 3 ce sont les états unis
d'amérique avec leurs 35 mille stations
de base très actif lors du déploiement
des réseaux mobile de génération
précédente
les chinois où avaient été eux ont
fournis et leurs antennes 3g et 4g aux
opérateurs du monde entier et en passant
à la 5g certaines régions se tournent de
nouveau vers les fournisseurs connu
malgré les protestations américaines
c'est par exemple le cas de l'afrique ce
continent reste un marché solide surtout
pour nous avait il fournit déjà des
antennes pour déployer des réseaux 5g
nationaux dans 10 pays africains
il n'y a perdu aucun client une des
raisons est son implantation sans
précédent en afrique selon diverses
estimations de 50 à 70% de
l'infrastructure africaine de haut débit
sans fil est équipé déjà par ou avec le
géant chinois a signé deux protocoles
d'entente avec l'union
africaine pour collaborer sur la 5g et
présent dans 40 pays africains
à ce jour moins cher que chez les
concurrents européens ou coréens
l'équipement ou avait possède un autre
atout crucial pour l'afrique
il amène avec lui des propositions
attrayant de prêts du gouvernement
chinois en financement qu aucun des
concurrents n'est en mesure de proposer
aujourd'hui
or les états unis veulent remédier à
cette lacune
selon le wall street journal washington
propose aux pays en développement des
prêts et des subventions pour acheter
l'équipement 5g européen ou coréens
autre point qu'il faut valoir c'est
l'existence présumée des portes dérobées
dans les antennes ou avait en effet
pékin a été au centre de plusieurs
scandales d'espionnage sur le continent
en 2018 le monde révèle que le siège de
l'union africaine construit par la chine
aurait été espionnée par pékin depuis
cinq ans en 2019 ou avait y aurait aidé
le gouvernement ougandais a infiltré les
messages whatsapp d'un opposant selon
toujours le wall street journal
des informations similaires ont ressurgi
en zambie ou encore en algérie
en effet à part taïwan aucun pays de la
région n'a rejoint l'initiative
américaine dite de réseau propre
pourtant au niveau du marché certaines
compagnies renonce de leur propre gré au
service de la veille et et e c'est le
cas notamment du japon est de singapour
là des restrictions de sécurité limitent
fortement l'utilisation de l'équipement
chinois soit il est interdit d'accès aux
appels d'offres publics soit il peut
équiper des réseaux d'accès mais pas des
réseaux coeur dans ces conditions
beaucoup de sociétés choisissent
d'autres partenaires au vietnam par
exemple l'opérateur
viettel utilisera ses propres
technologies pour déployer la 5g sans
s'adresser à des équipementiers externe
en corée du sud
un seul des trois grands réseaux de
télécoms a opté pour nous avait pourtant
dans le reste de la région où la veille
compte décrocher une position dominante
grâce aux coups
train en malaisie au même chez les
alliés américains que sont les
philippines et la thaïlande reste
l'indonésie qui ne projettent pas encore
de passer à la 5g et l'inde ou la
position des autorités sur ou avaient
été eux aussi en fonction des tensions
avec la chine même état des lieux en
amérique latine où les sociétés
chinoises avancent à grands pas pourtant
elle pourrait bientôt perdre la part la
plus appétissante du marché le brésil
selon bloomberg sous pressions
américaines croissantes le président
bolle sonar ont réfléchi à interdire
spécifiquement ou avec washington menace
de cesser les investissements américains
dans le pays puis offre un milliard de
dollars de prêts pour acheter
l'équipement 5g d'autres prestataires
un vrai dilemme pour le brésil pour qui
la chine est le premier partenaire
commercial
aujourd'hui la solution à ce casse-tête
pourrait passer par une voie médiane
choisi par exemple en france sans
interdire complètement l'équipement
chinois paris introduit à un régime
d'autorisation temporaire sur avis de l'
agence nationale de la sécurité des
systèmes d'information ainsi il est
interdit à orange et free qui n'ont pas
encore d'antenne chinoise de collaborer
avec ou à veille sur la 5g en france par
contre pour bouygues et sfr qui possède
déjà plusieurs centaines d'antenne ou
avait 5 g dans l'hexagone la nes et 6
propose un compromis
les deux opérateurs devront démonter
l'équipement ou avait mais pour cela ils
auront huit ans et devront le faire
seulement dans les zones très denses où
près des sites stratégiques sensibles
comme par exemple le port militaire de
brest
aucune entreprise quelle que soit sa
nationalité n'est visé mais la volonté
est affirmée alors que nous avons deux
fournisseurs européens ericsson et nokia
d'avoir une vraie solution industrielle
européenne pleinement sécurisée sous nos
législations l'approchent française est
unique et les conciliante d'un côté mais
protectrice de l'autre par contre
l'espagne l'autriche la hongrie ou
encore la suisse ont déjà laissé leurs
portes grandes ouvertes à la 5g chinoise
quelle place sur le marché mondial les
chinois conserve-t-il après une année
difficile
et bien malgré tous ces obstacles ou
avait et reste le fournisseur le plus
populaire d'équipement 5g au monde avec
28 5% des parts de marché ericsson est
juste derrière avec 25% vient ensuite
nokia avec 22 % 8 5% sont réservés au
coréen samsung
le fournisseur publique chinoise et e
clôt ce top 5 qui ne compte aucune
compagnie américaine le gagnant de cette
course remportera des bénéfices
économiques énormes
quel est le but final de la campagne
américaine anti ou avec les fabricants
chinois pourront-ils encore conserver
leur domination mondiale face à toutes
ces pressions pour mieux comprendre tout
cela nous rejoignons à nouveau yann maël
l'arrière docteur en droit social et
spécialistes du numérique
monsieur larrère les sociétés
européennes comme nokia ou ericsson
pourront-elles selon vous faire
concurrence aux compagnies chinoises
dans le futur est ce qu elles ont pris
un retard qu'on ne peut plus combler
alors en réalité non d'ailleurs on voit
aujourd'hui il ya un fort rattrapage de
nokia et d'ericsson en particulier à l'
exxon puisque nokia avait déjà déployés
en amont a quasiment en même temps d
antenne singer dans différents pays et
notamment aux états unis
mais aujourd'hui eux c'est ericsson
d'ailleurs qui rattrape le plus son
retard entre guillemets son retard
relatif
parce que ils arrivent à proposer une
technologie assez compétitive en termes
de coût et d'efficacité
ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut bien
préciser c'est que les opérateurs qui
avaient déjà des antennes 4g deurne d'un
d'un fournisseur
eh ben ils ont tendance à vouloir
chercher le même fournisseur de 5 g donc
oui oui par exemple en france étaient
avait installé beaucoup d'antennes pour
sfr et donc
sfr va se tourner naturellement pour
améliorer pour awd les antennes kadjé
vers la 5g vers l'opérateur
enfin vers le constructeur d'antenne à
quel auquel il avait déjà l'habitude de
faire appel et c'est la même chose pour
les autres
certains experts disent qu'il faut
contourner le standard 5 g est implanté
tout de suite la cij et ont-ils raison
et surtout est ce possible alors c'est
un peu un but qu parce que effectivement
on aimerait bien j'imagine en déployer
tout de suite la cij est encore plus
performante on nous promet 10 100 fois
plus performante que la 5g en réalité il
ya des cycles sur eux sur chaque
technologie mobile qui dure dix ans il
faut dix ans pour développer une
nouvelle technologie une nouvelle
connectivité et on arrive juste au tout
début de la 5g qui a encore des marges
de progrès d'ailleurs à faire on l'a
évoqué et pour la cij et on est au tout
début du développement du coup ça validé
d'ici dix ans donc on est en 2020 peut
qu'on peut dire quel sujet sera prête en
merci beaucoup yann maia l'arrière je
rappelle vous êtes docteur en droit
social est spécialiste du numérique
merci d'avoir apporté votre analyse dans
cette émission merci beaucoup
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]